well South Africa's President says
Vladimir Putin will not be attending a
summit in Johannesburg next month
Russia's president was invited to join
other leaders from the brics
cross-border trade group so ramaphosam
says that foreign minister Sergey lavrov
will be representing Russia there
instead the international criminal court
has issued an arrest warrant for
Russia's president for suspected war
crimes in Ukraine now as a signatory to
the ICC South Africa would have a duty
to arrest Putin if he arrived there well
let's crossed her for me to Miller she's
in March in South Africa a family this
must be a bit of a relief for ramaphosa
well it certainly is uh for president
who was in a very difficult position
given as you mentioned that South Africa
is a signatory to the Rome statute and
so then would be bound uh to uh arrest
uh the Russian president if he had come
to South Africa that's I suppose the
legal side of the Dilemma but many in
South Africa would argue that the South
African presidents of African government
and the uh governing party in South
Africa the ANC had no intention at any
time to arrest Vladimir Putin South
Africa has a good relationship with
Russia we also see deepening ties
through organizations like bricks and
that Summit coming up in about a month's
time so that really was the Dilemma for
South Africa this very good relationship
with Russia but being a signatory to the
Rome statute and this is why in recent
weeks we've heard more calls from some
South African parties the ANC
specifically saying that South Africa
should pull out of international
treaties and organizations that don't
serve South African interests South
Africa is a sovereign country and
shouldn't be dictated to but given this
formal decision which wasn't the read
the invitation uh being rescinded it was
an agreement a mutual agreement the
South African government says this
certainly does make the way forward a
bit easier famina let me ask you about
the timing because I see that ramaphosa
filed what was originally a confidential
Court affidavit saying that he believes
that arresting Putin would only escalate
hostilities in Ukraine that's also been
very controversial when you look at how
politically divisive this has already
been
well given the African National
congress's position on its relationship
with Russia with Vladimir Putin and in
by extensions the South African
government uh they've been very certain
about what they've wanted to do but of
course they've been challenged by an
opposition party like the Democratic
Alliance who has taken the government to
court saying that it should be forced to
arrest Putin should he come to South
Africa we now know that's not happening
and because of that the South African
president had to provide had to provide
a responding affidavit to the courts in
South Africa explaining why the
government had that position why they
would admit not arrest Putin he was also
forced to make this affidavit public and
in it ramaphosa had said that and the
rest of Putin would be unlawful and it
would be tantamount to declaring war on
Russia now the Russians have also
responded the presidential spokesperson
saying Russia has at no point threatened
South Africa but of course an arrest of
Putin a war would be a threat would be
an attack on the president so again this
comes back to this mutual agreement
between the two countries trying to
navigate A Way Forward giving these
deepening ties South African government
has of course had some opposition to
this decision that it's made or the
statements it's made in recent weeks
around its what's supposed to be a
protection of Putin and so it's likely
now that that Court challenge will fall
away because Putin is no longer
traveling to South Africa and family
just in the last few minutes I see the
Kremlin says that Putin will be
participating in that Summit but only
via video call very interesting
development family Miller across all of
that for us in South Africa thank you